i had this like pipe dream of working at
like you know a big tech company and and
it seemed so far off when i first
started learning and it was like it'd be
really cool if i could work at some big
tech company and like work on these
products that like millions of people
use that'd be so cool
but i just like honestly in in if i was
being totally honest just never saw
myself getting there
hi all and welcome to mooco's corner
it's a show about leading a life that
feels more you in your life and tech
career i'm your host mayuko and invite
you as always to come in sit down maybe
today grab a cup of coffee because
you're probably gonna want it after
listening to this one and enjoy the show
so today on the show we have caleb caleb
is a lifelong tanker specialty coffee
geek and loves building cool things
he enjoys spending time with his family
staying current on the latest in tech
and visiting new coffee shops so hi
caleb how are you doing how's your week
been
hey yeah uh thanks again for having me
i'm super excited to be here just to
chat about you know fun tech stuff
coffee stuff etc
uh my week's going pretty well just uh
you know catching up after the long
weekend and continuing on all the stuff
i'm working on it at work and just you
know living family life and
just you know
awesome love it okay so for context
caleb and i i think we've followed each
other on instagram for a while now i
don't even remember how i found you
originally maybe it was for your coffee
content i i think i remember actually i
think
oh yeah so i've been following you for a
while and then i talk occasionally on my
instagram about tech stuff that i do
outside of coffee um and i like think i
tagged you as as a list of like a couple
other tech accounts that i follow
because i was working on some like
refactoring or something so i was like
tagging a bunch of people that might
care and so i think you were like whoa
hey like cool coffee content we just
kind of started chatting so i think
that's how maybe we met but um but yeah
been following you a long time
yeah internet friends
yeah
i mean so i'm really so actually this is
the first time that i've really gotten
to talk to caleb in the synchronous
environment we were just talking before
the show so yeah this show i'm really
excited to kind of just like get to know
kayla because we have a lot of things in
common of we both have experience
breaking it into it caleb's actually at
intuit right now um we're both ios
developers or you know i was an ios
developer so we have that kind of like
similar career thread and we both love
coffee caleb probably maybe likes coffee
more than me because he makes a lot of
coffee content on instagram but like i
love talking to people about coffee
because i think it's just so interesting
and you don't i feel like i don't know i
don't come across that many people who
are truly interested in all the
different aspects there are not to judge
anybody who's not but you know what i
mean
yeah yeah yeah it's a it's a niche group
for sure i guess we'll start with kind
of like career stuff because you know a
lot of the people who are watching
listening to the show are kind of in
tech already and so caleb tell me a
little bit about what you do at intuit
currently yeah yeah so um like you said
i am an ios engineer i've been doing ios
for
i'm not at into it but in general for
about six years and so yeah add into it
i work on the quickbooks checking team
and quickbooks checking is a particular
feature inside of the quickbooks app um
and so i work on
you know implementing new features and
also like the kind of work that goes
into
maintaining uh the existing
functionality that we have
improving automation things like that um
so yeah day to day i'm working on you
know the future of quickbooks checking
that is very familiar to me because uh i
used to work on quickbooks mobile before
like i mean like quickbooks mobile i
feel like has had an interesting history
of like it used to be um two different
apps and then it was one app and then i
was actually only there for six months
because i was there for um my rotational
program so i did a year at turbo tax on
the turbotax universal team and then i
went to quickbooks and so we actually
probably might have uh like uh mutual
mutual connections mutual friends
co-workers kind of thing yeah i actually
don't know if i know anybody into it
anymore just because i i left in like
2015 or something like that and you
joined in the last two years right yeah
i joined in november 2020 yeah so um a
little over a year i think did i message
him yeah a little over a year um so yeah
i i maybe will know some people but but
maybe not so how how do you like working
it into it so far how has it been yeah i
honestly love it um i
cannot speak more highly of just my my
team in general but just the overall
culture of the company i have been
really impressed
from the very beginning about how much
they they genuinely care about their
employees um
i i get a sense that it's very honest
and very genuine that the company wants
their employees to be well taken care of
to take care of themselves well
which is like something that companies
don't always do both um and some
companies say a lot but then like you
don't see the follow through from like
upper management or like the people who
are like overseeing the people getting
their hands dirty and and i see like
really great um like demonstrational
leadership from like upper management
and even like my manager in taking time
off and like um you know having things
to do outside of work and ensuring that
people are able to like live and not
just work so that's something that i
really love about just the culture of
working there
and um you know i really believe in what
they're doing to help empower prosperity
around the world and empowering small
businesses to do what they do and that's
something that i love on like a personal
note just like being able to contribute
to people's livelihoods around the world
um so that's that's
a few of the things that i like but
overall like really great experience so
far that's awesome i i feel like i
totally get what you mean like i started
my career into it and so like i was kind
of like i don't really know anything
else um but since then you know working
at other companies and stuff and
reflecting on my time there i also got
the sense that like people are really
well taken care of it into it because
like i feel like it's hard to find
companies in tech where like people have
worked there for 10 15 years like
when i was working there there were
people who were like i've been working
here for maybe longer than you've been
alive kind of thing i'm just like
dang like that's a long time
i was like 20 at the time so you know
but like that that to me was just like
oh they people are really well taken
care of here no totally i i have
co-workers that i work with who've been
there for 15 plus years and like one of
the people who interviewed me like one
of the things that actually clued me in
that it might be a good place to work
for is one of the interviewers had been
there 20 years and like i had never even
heard of that in the world of tech like
people do this like people have been in
the same company or like in the same
field for that long and it um was like
huh like there must be something that's
keeping them
them here and and i think honestly just
the care that intuit takes with their
employees is a big factor totally and i
think it was i mean you know like we're
we probably were surrounded by similar
people and that we you know we were both
were on like an ios team but i remember
when i was there it was uh i a lot of
people had been there for 20 years but
they obviously hadn't been doing ios 12
for 20 years because ios development
wasn't that old but like a lot of them
were like mac developers who
were doing mac development on the turbo
tax mac app and then they were able to
transition to doing ios and so i think
about the people that i work with there
and it's it's like it's given me more a
lot of perspective i guess because it's
just like oh like you can have i don't
know i like the thing you said about
like oh you can have like a 20-year
career is like
you just don't really hear about that
that often like a lot of tech employees
are i feel like the ones that i've
tended to work with were like under the
age of 45 kind of thing and so
like it's just you just don't hear about
it like i i often wonder i'm like what
what would it be like to be in tech when
i'm 50 60. like what is that like you
know and
like intuit has those people which is
really fascinating that's true yeah yeah
it's really cool i i get to work with a
lot of different people from a lot of
different walks of life with like very
different careers as far as like the
things they've been able to do and and
the way that they got into it and
into it i cannot i can't make i can't
not make that joke once a day by mistake
that happens all the time like i feel
like you just say it and then people are
like and i'm like oh my gosh stop
um anyway but like it's it's really cool
to get to work with um people who have
been there so long and like have a
really deep understanding of kind of the
product and the company as a whole and i
think it's a good testament to the way
they do things totally yeah and so i
guess like i'm curious also about your
ios development experience like how did
you get into ios and like how's that
been for you yeah yeah that's a good
question it's um
it's kind of a weird
non-traditional approach uh that i took
i went to a four-year university in in
oregon and i graduated with a degree in
elementary education so like not at all
a cs degree not a tech degree i was
going to go into teaching and i did
for
three or four three years taught in the
public school systems in oregon and then
i my wife and i moved to indonesia and
we got to teach at an international
school in indonesia which was um just a
amazing amazing experience
absolutely loved that but while i was
teaching i kind of realized that there
was this side of me that i was really
invested in technology and really you
know um on a personal level
but
you know didn't really get to use that a
lot in the way that i taught i i
integrated that in my teaching to like
help train kids to like use technology
and actually actually beneficial ways
and not just like here's an ipad like go
watch some youtube videos and learn some
stuff
which you know of course is like an
amazing way to learn things but um as a
teacher i struggle to find ways to to
really use technology in the way that i
wanted to and at the end of the day it
kind of boiled down to me realizing
that i wanted to create with technology
and not just like use it as a tool so i
wanted to actually be creating the
technology so i started kind of looking
into like what would it take to get
there and found some online courses on
on udemy and and started kind of just
taking courses and reading
books um i don't know if you're familiar
with the big nerd ranch books oh yeah
that's a famous one yeah i learned with
that one too
yeah
yeah so um i went through some udemy
courses and got the the swift
programming book from the big nerd ranch
uh people
and just kind of started diving in and
getting my hands dirty yeah so um at
that point i got a job at a learn to
code company so i was using kind of my
like teaching skills and taking the
topics i was learning and then
translating that into basically teaching
those skills again in course format
and i worked with them for a number of
years and then after uh that career or
that uh after that job i ended up
getting a job at a creative agency doing
ios development so it was kind of like
this stepping stone from like teaching
to teaching ios development to then
doing ios development but like in um an
agency format which is different than
when you're working at like a
corporation like intuit or netflix or
like a big company it's just different
like it's the same work but there's um i
don't know like maybe
less ownership because it's like a
client will bring you a project and you
do the project and then you ship it off
you may never see it again or like they
may not you know have the funds to like
keep you on to keep like working on it
and introducing updates so it feels kind
of weird like you build this project you
put your like blood sweat and tears into
it and then you kind of ship it off and
it's gone whereas like where i'm at now
which is intuit which is the job after
the agency job um i feel like a really
deep sense of ownership because it's
like this continuous product that's
going to be around you know for a very
long time and and it's something that i
build into every day people use it every
day so there's there's a lot of
ownership there but anyway long story
short that's basically my my journey
from
learning to code uh all the way to like
teaching to teaching coding to coding to
now i'm like doing what i wanted to be
doing from the very beginning which is
building and creating the technology
that i that i was interested in that's
awesome that's so like gradual i think
that that's what's really interesting
about your journey i think like whenever
anybody comes into tech from a
non-traditional background like they
didn't study computer science a lot of
it is just like that individual has to
kind of like take it upon themselves to
teach themselves and then find that
first job and opportunity and stuff but
like i find that like especially for
people who you know did work did some
something completely different from i
was relevant before there is that kind
of like stepping stone element of just
like i'm doing kind of an in-between
thing and then i do the full thing which
is really cool because at the end of the
day it's like you get to bring so many
different parts of yourself to one job
and then you're kind of i like to think
of it as like product development where
you're like iterating on yourself and
your career towards where you want to go
because it's also like i don't know i i
don't know about you but i didn't really
know where i wanted to go at the
beginning but then it's like you realize
while you're doing it more and more what
you like and what you don't like right
yeah totally no i think that's a really
a good way of putting it iterating on
yourself and like not only just like
your skills but even like your mindset
on like what you want to be doing and i
remember like when i first
you know
started considering like i want to be an
ios engineer um i had this like pipe
dream of working at like you know a big
tech company and and it seems so far off
when i first started learning and it was
like it'd be really cool if i could work
at some big tech company and like work
on these products that like millions of
people use that'd be so cool
but i just like honestly in in if i was
being totally honest just never saw
myself getting there but then as time
has progressed and like as i've learned
and grown i now find myself like exactly
where i kind of had dreamed of being at
a big tech company where like i am
getting to build these these cool
products and it's just like amazing to
kind of see
um even if it's like a slower longer
journey than you imagine like you
uh i i don't know how to say this in a
non-cheesy way but like it's really
possible to get there like i i went from
a non-tech background and now i'm
working at a big tech company doing what
i like really love doing um so i don't
know if that's inspiration or just like
super cheesy but there's my campy
inspirational quote of the day
but i mean that i mean we'll take the
inspiration right i think a lot of
people watching and listening are
probably exactly where you were you know
five six years ago when you were just
starting out so there's your inspiration
of the day folks from caleb
we need like a little like star like
animation
yeah
that's amazing okay so i kind of want to
switch gears a little bit um into kind
of the coffee world because yeah this is
something that i've gotten really into i
think like ever since i don't know maybe
like a few years ago or something and i
that really truly your instagram is so
beautiful like i genuinely get so much
like joy out of looking at the stuff
that you create they're like you know
it's another product that you're
creating sure you're making ios apps for
small businesses by day and then you're
creating this beautiful coffee content
by night so can you tell us a little bit
about kind of like your coffee
presents hobby influencing i don't know
what you call it business whatever it
might be
yeah it's a lot of things um
thank you first of all that's really
kind of you to say that and and it's
just it's something that i
you know um discovered i kind of had a
knack for or a passion for and um you
know in a previous job actually i was
sort of tasked with taking over the
social media account um and like really
dove into kind of like how does that
work and how does how does a business
find success on instagram um to kind of
use instagram as a lead generation tool
for our company and i dove into that and
got you know okay at it like i you know
i realized like i'm kind of decent at
growing this profile so when that job
ended i i realized like i really like
this content creation piece but i don't
really have like an avenue for it
anymore
and so i was starting to think like
maybe i could just kind of do it for
myself like i could make myself into
like a brand and like you understand
that with what you do on youtube and
elsewhere
and so basically i just decided like
let's pick something that i love to do
and let's just start taking photos of it
and talking about it and and it honestly
was as uh you know i
content creation is is difficult it
requires intentionality and and
forethought um but i think like at its
most foundational like primitive level
it requires just doing the thing
and like it's so um easy to get caught
up on like how do i brand this right and
how do i i don't have a nice camera or i
don't know what to talk about and
honestly it was like this is a bag of
coffee i bought i think it tastes like
this and i brewed it this way and it
like started out so simple and and
that's really what i like try to do
today even is just kind of to capture
what i'm doing on instagram i basically
post content about the specialty coffee
scene you know roasters and different
brewing methods and just tips and tricks
and techniques i also do kind of reviews
of coffee gear and i i'm often like sent
samples of new and upcoming products to
kind of showcase and tell people about
so they know where to where to pick them
up to to support businesses that are you
know
making the coffee world special and and
um that's basically what i do so
aside from that my goal at the end of
the day is that people connect with me
uh even more than they connect with my
content
and
something that i've kind of learned to
believe along the way and like this
really ties into my my journey and
learning to code as well is that like
i've come to believe
in myself as a scarce resource and what
i mean by that is like i i am the only
one who can create content the way that
i do and like i am the unique part of it
like anybody can take pictures of a cup
of coffee but like the way that i do it
and the way that i communicate about it
is unique to me and like no one else can
really do that and that was really like
an empowering mindset for me to be able
to like
just fearlessly post what i'm going to
post and not worry about you know what
people are going to think about it or or
you know
let that hold me back from creating just
realizing like
you know this is kind of a unique thing
that i can bring to the table even
though there are other people doing
similar things and making similar
content um it's it's something that i
really love to do and i've kind of
learned to think about that way so i
kind of went on a little rabbit trail
there but that's in essence what i do
with with coffee stuff and it's uh it's
a lot of fun i love like all of that
like all of that resonates with me so
strongly like like you make like using
yourself as a scarce resource and just
like trying things out and like creating
content to get people to relate to you
as a person like i really think that is
what's powerful about content creation
but really just like it's not just not
just
content creation it's just creation in
general ios apps web apps coffee content
instagram posts tick tocks what have you
right because you it's it's i mean at
the end of the day i like to think of it
as like a method of self-expression and
even if the same two people make the
same thing it's gonna it's gonna feel
different and i also think like it's
okay if two people make the same thing
because like i think rising tides raise
all boats you know like it's it's
awesome when there's more and more
people who are talking about the same
thing using their own perspective i mean
like i think i think it helps so like i
relate to you on like some of the kind
of tech stuff too but like i okay after
looking at your stuff i want an espresso
machine i want an origami dripper
i literally actually went and bought um
there was like some yemeni beans that
you recommended from canada that i
bought i think it was vocal button yeah
yeah you were like okay so like okay
we're gonna dive deep now y'all
um okay when we think about coffee
content i think of james hoffman because
he's like he's just he uh he's like he's
like the casey neistat yeah like the
coffee world right and so i think i
watched a video about how yemeni beans
um yet like coffee beans grown in yemen
which is like this whole new thing you
know it's about growing coffee in a more
sustainable way because a lot of these
coffee beans that are grown in like
south america and africa um experience
are experiencing climate change like
everywhere else and so it's really hard
to get the crops versus these beans in
yemen are hardy like they're so hearty
and so they're very different and so i
watched this video by james hoffman
explaining this to me and then at the
time i think it was like i looked up
like beans and then i was like these
beans are expensive it's like a hundred
dollars for a bad kind of thing but i
was so curious and then you recommended
this bag and i was just like wait okay
like someone closer to me is
recommending this specific bag so i
bought it and it was unreal it's like
like it's so florally i feel like uh
yeah
tea like that's exactly what it's like
like whenever i drink beans from yemen i
think it reminds me of chamomile tea
which it's you know i'm just like it's
but it's coffee but it's tea it's coffee
but it's cheap yeah anyways rabbit hole
no no no totally i'm all for it yeah so
in that james hoffman video he was
talking about that farm in yemen and
just how amazing it is that they even
can produce coffee because of like the
the climate and the terrain and just
it's very difficult and there's not much
farmable land in the whole country so
the fact that like these farms exist is
kind of like miraculous and they're able
to cultivate these really delicious
coffee crops and like i think
the fact that it's so hard to grow kind
of plays into why it's so expensive and
why it's kind of like a hyper specialty
coffee because
like it's incredibly difficult to grow
but it's it's cool that farmers are are
able to sell their coffees and and like
sustain their families with with this
the kind of
relatively new crop that's um you know
being exported now and sold to roasters
around uh canada i know there are some
us roasters that also roast you many
coffee but um yeah it's it's always fun
to
learn about like kind of up and coming
origins in the coffee world like um
another one is uh yunnan in china is
another region that has coffee and i had
no idea coffee was grown in china yeah i
had a bag sent to me from uh another
canadian roaster called rabbit hole
roasters and they also have yemeni
coffees as well but um yeah they sent me
a bag of it to like try and it was
almost like this like lemongrass tea
like very interesting like and it's
funny like for for people who like are
not really into coffee like you probably
have like an idea of what coffee tastes
like and i just want to say like coffee
can taste so different from like
different beans different beans and
it's like so diverse and it's something
that like there's like that classic
coffee flavor like like a coffee candy
has like that classic
old school kind of coffee flavor but it
can be like so much more and it really
depends on kind of the coffees that you
buy
100
okay i'm going to back this up like a
lot right now because let's do it like i
just realized i was like all right okay
we're diving into like coffee nerdy
territory and like maybe we should uh
bring people along for the ride a little
bit because there are a lot of people
who don't drink coffee right but like i
think okay so one thing that i wanted to
talk to you specifically about is this
kind of intersection of coffee and the
tech industry because i think that's
where a lot of this kind of stuff starts
at least for me that's where it started
like i started getting into coffee
because my husband
works at a startup where one guy is so
into coffee and so he like he just
brought this whole culture of like
making pour overs at work
and so my husband started getting into
it he brought it home and now i'm really
into it but like i it's just a thing i
think in the tech industry of like hey
you want to go grab a cup of coffee um i
think part of it is because like the
tech industry is centered in san
francisco and there's a lot of good you
know uh like coffee cafe
roasters and stuff there too but like i
don't know if you also know um
the ios community had a coffee meet up
and their url used to be like coffee
coffee coffee.coffee or something like
that i don't know if you ever heard
about this but no
there's these kind of
overlaps i think between the tech and
coffee world right and so i'm kind of
curious about like you know because i
think like there's this yeah it's a
thing it's just like hey let's go
do a coffee one on one let's go to a
cafe one-on-one sort of thing like why
do you think why do you think tech
people are starting to cough i don't
know
yeah but like why is there an overlap i
mean i i don't know i i think you're
right like i definitely
i definitely think there's like a
some type of this like unspoken
relationship between the tech world and
the coffee world and like i don't know
when i think of engineers tend to be
pretty like detail driven and like tend
to be pretty kind of like meticulous in
the weeds with like all the details of
this and that and coffee can be that way
too if you're like really into the
details of it it's like kind of
chemistry like i mean yeah okay
yeah like every person that i've gotten
into coffee because you know once you
like coffee you can't help but talk
about coffee with everybody
believe me i talk about it literally
every day on instagram yeah right yeah
literally that's what you do but it's
like there's something about the ritual
of like pouring your pore over every
morning or like pulling an espresso shot
even if it's like the work espresso
machine or even if even if it's a keurig
or whatever like there's just a ritual
to it and like there's something about i
mean i think there's something about
caffeine and technology too because
that's definitely a thing of like
software engineers drink red bulls while
they code kind of stuff but i think that
kind of translates into coffee but less
like
aggro
yeah yeah definitely yeah a little less
like organic little less natural but
yeah
yeah totally yeah
i don't know like i i would be curious
to look back in time and see how this
all
started i don't know that i have any
like
aha you know insights as to why but
it's just like to me sometimes i'm just
like this like it is niche to have this
overlap of coffee and tech but it it's
so a thing like there are so many people
like when i meet another tech person out
in the wild i do kind of test to see if
they like i don't test isn't like are
you a real coffee nerd but like like
i mean it's just like it's there's a
good chance that they're also kind of
into coffee and so i'm kind of just like
like what kind of coffee like are you
into coffee like what kind of coffee are
you into sort of thing
not that there's any right or wrong way
to be into coffee because i don't judge
but like i mean i personally just really
like light roast pour overs because i
just think it's like it
like you said there's so many different
flavors and i think that's one of the
most interesting ways to experience it
but yeah i don't know it's just it's
just fascinating to me that there's like
this whole thing yeah it's funny i
actually kind of do the same thing like
when i meet someone and they're like if
they mention coffee or if it comes up
like i always ask like well like how do
you how do you brew your coffee and the
answer that will like always tell me
kind of like are you like
into it are you like
serious about it like
are you gonna care about the processing
method of the beans are you gonna care
about like what mineral supplements are
you adding to your water to like get the
most tasty flavorful filtered water like
nerdy stuff like that's i i want to know
i want to know the details yeah yeah
yeah okay okay let's let's do a little
bit of role play right now so like say
that you and i we met at some tech event
maybe i started working at intuit again
or something like that and then you
asked me
what kind of coffee i'm into or if i'm
into coffee or something and i say i'm
just like okay i say that which this is
the truth i'm really into v-60s and
aeropresses and i brew light roasts and
i literally go fetch water from a like a
well
that sounds really it smells really
intense but like literally like nearby
there's a place where you can get like
um water from a wat like an underground
water reserve and it's alkaline water
and i realize that it's so good for
brewing coffee
um after realizing that the fridge water
just won't cut it
so that's my answer where where do you
go next like what do you think
my first response would be we are like
the same person oh okay
i mean like that's like the level of
detail i'd love to get into i guess i
would ask you you know if you had like
measured the tds levels of the water to
determine the parts per million of
particles uh oh like minerals to like
the water yeah cause it's like magnesium
and like all of those
play a really big difference right i
actually haven't done that there's
there's different things it's
interesting because like a tds meter
only will tell you like the parts per
million of like um non-dissolved or
sorry of dissolved solids in your water
but it won't tell you what they are so
there's something else that like serious
coffee nerds and like i say this being a
serious coffee nerd i don't have one so
i'm like sad but they're like they're so
expensive it's called um a refractometer
and like it's used in chemistry but like
people use it in the coffee world where
basically you like there's a little um
like a port on the top and you can drip
the coffee in
this little port and it shines light
through it and it can actually tell you
like
what
the composition of of the water is or
the coffee
and like the percentage of coffee to
water of like how much of an extraction
yield did you actually get and people in
yeah it's it's crazy like how technical
people can get i'll send you a profile
of someone uh named jonathan he's like
an actual chemist who his whole thing is
like the actual like intense chemistry
of coffee and it's amazing stuff what
that's so cool
yeah he's really really cool um has some
really like crazy stuff that he does and
experiments but like all these
a lot of the people who are like really
really into this level of meticulousness
are like looking for super high
extraction yields of like you know 24
extracted coffee 26 whatever you know
and and based on how you brew it you'll
get like wildly different results so
everything from like the grind size to
the water temperature to like the actual
filter paper used to
even just like the pouring techniques
like all of this different all these
different things go into it and yeah
it's wild that like these like because
when i was first getting into i'm like
what's really the difference between a
v60 and a chemex truly or like how like
why how how how can it taste so
different from regular drip coffee
but it really does i which is what i'm
always surprised about of like how the
beans get extracted what's like how fine
the gr the grind is is also a really big
difference in that the water the water
temperature like there's just so many
different
variables that can yield a completely
different cup of coffee
and so it just goes so deep
yeah totally yeah it's it's crazy like
all the different um like you said
variables that go into it and maybe
that's part of it part of the overlap
with tech we've got some variables in
there
maybe maybe experimentation yeah there
you go yeah good good
um but no like yeah it's crazy how
you know you can get a coffee
and
brew it like you brewed the last coffee
you got and get like a very different
result even like the same coffee
depending on like when it was roasted if
it was roasted the day before
and you brew it it might be like you
know it might taste one way and it
honestly like a lot of people recommend
waiting like a week or two after it's
roasted to like could be optimally you
know kind of the optimal window but um
like if you if you brew it right after
it's roasted versus two weeks after
versus like two months after you get
like wildly different results even if
the variables are all the same just like
that one variable you can't really
control which is like the
the time off roast um
yeah like even that can make a big
difference in how how the cup comes out
and you might have to make kind of
adaptations to the way that you brew to
to um
you know really get the result that you
want so
totally i mean even even something as
like controllable as like when you first
have a hot cup of a pour over and then
30 minutes later when it's cooled down
completely different flavors like
completely different way that it
expresses itself and so like before i
used to be like oh i'm so sad that you
let my coffee like be cold but it's it's
like it's literally like a different cup
of coffee truly like oh cool a new cup
and now it's cold so yeah
it's like a brand new cup yeah i find
that coffees with um like kind of
citrusy or like berry flavored notes um
when they cool down it gets like really
intense and like almost like tangy like
it's like juice like it's so weird how
that can like really become very bright
and and present um where like it might
be kind of hidden when it's warmer and
totally yeah well okay so since you're
so i feel like you're kind of on the
bleeding edge of like of coffee
technology new beans brewing methods and
stuff like tell me about like a new
because i always see you like like using
different gadgets and beans and stuff
like that what's like an a recent kind
of like thing that you tried that you
were like wow like this is incredibly
exciting yeah there is one thing that
comes to mind it's actually like not
really like a manual brew thing it's
it's more of an automated thing but it
is like a redemption of a coffee brewing
device that i had basically written off
is like not good that has been redeemed
in my opinion and now i like i'm really
excited about so
um
i'm sure like you mentioned keurig
earlier i'm sure you're familiar with
nespresso
um so there is a company in
singapore i believe called morning and
they have a machine called the morning
machine and it's basically a nespresso
pod compatible machine
that can brew the coffees from nespresso
pods
but specialty roasters from like all
around the world are starting to put
their really good coffees in nespresso
pods instead of like kind of the yeah
yeah like that alone is like really cool
so like
uh there's one called april coffee
roasters from copenhagen and they like
started doing this where they're putting
their coffees in in espresso pods and
the cool thing with this machine i wish
i could like turn my camera and show you
but just go check out my instagram for
some content on it
but basically the machine is like a
space machine like you can put the pod
in the machine just like any other
nespresso machine but then there is a
dial on the front that you can like
twist and change everything from like
the pressure profile of like how much
pressure it puts on the coffee and how
much um
how much water you want to run through
like i want 80 grams of coffee or 40
grams of coffee um you can set like the
temperature of the water like every
variable you can actually control on the
machine um it has a built-in scale so
like when it starts to pull the coffee
through the nespresso pod it like will
measure it automatically and stop once
it's hit like your target yield it has a
tds meter built in so you can actually
see the like parts per million of the
water as
as you're brewing the coffee um
it's like super cool and then you can
also just use it to run hot water
through to do um the in the machine they
call it like kyoto drip style coffee for
like those little drip bags that you can
like tear the top off and it'll do the
whole like brew process for actually
like you know
dripping it just slowly enough so it
doesn't overflow that drip bag and it's
like so cool like really versatile and
it is shocking like
how good the coffee is from an espresso
pod like i never thought i would get
like what i consider tasty coffee from
an espresso pod but it's like it's
shockingly amazing and
like wow yeah so anyway okay wait so is
it is it because so is the nespress like
you just buy like an espresso pod from
like target kind of thing like if you
brew with that machine it's good or is
it these specialty coffee beans that are
packed in espresso pods that are good
because i've also written off this
nespresso pods a little bit because i'm
just like they're so dark
like i'm not a huge fan of the really
really dark kind of drip coffee kind of
stuff so i've just been like i need a
lot of milk and sugar for that kind of
stuff so like what like what is it about
all of that
yeah i'm gonna say the same thing i
would say for drip coffee even like uh
like a drip machine
buying good coffee to begin with is
always going to be like your absolute
best first step if you want to get
better coffee so if you buy you know
coffee from the grocery store um
often times it's going to be fairly old
fairly off roads maybe like four or five
months and you don't you don't really
know the quality of the beans you don't
really know like how they were roasted
they could be like roasted to oblivion
to where there's like not much coffee
left and it's just kind of char that's
that's left um and if you like the taste
of that that's fine like you know drink
coffee the way that you like drink
coffee uh you know of course i don't i
don't judge and and that's not you know
for me to decide you know what's best
for you to drink but but the coffees
that i like uh to drink are also kind of
light roast like you mentioned and i
think honestly the big thing is that
yeah specialty roasters are putting
really like tasty good coffees that they
have like roasted to perfection
um and the the
ability of the machine to kind of dial
in the settings to to put the right
amount of pressure at the right
temperature and extract the right amount
is something that's cool to be able to
kind of play with and optimize uh what
you get out because like a standard
nespresso machine as far as i'm aware
you just like put the pod in and push go
and it just does what it does
um but with this you get a lot more
precision and a lot more like ability to
kind of dial in the coffee and get get
exactly the result you want um and
that's one thing that i really like it's
i think it's a mix of both really good
coffee and like really great tech to be
able to extract it well that's so cool
i'm totally gonna check it out after
this yeah yeah it's pretty sweet whoa
that is so cool
well um i think we're basically at time
actually thanks so much for being on the
show where can people find you i guess
on the internet yes on the internet good
question um yeah my handle on instagram
is at gurukala
that's a nod back to my teaching days in
indonesia guru is the word for teacher
in
indonesian so that's where that came
from uh anyway but yeah at gurukala
on instagram and that's honestly pretty
much the only place i am these days i i
decided to simplify and just be on
instagram only so definitely go check
out his stuff literally the espresso
polls that he films are like butter like
literally so beautiful things of beauty
i kid you not
liquid gold liquid gold exactly you can
listen to this episode of mucus corner
through your favorite podcasting app